it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and all-around nerd
and i am a dinosaur in beauty blogger
years i started my blog in december 2011
and in the last almost 10 years i have
learnt a lot as i've read way too deeply into
everything so i had the urge to go
through some of my older posts recently
and unsurprisingly i've said quite a few
myths in the past like the infamous mineral
sunscreens work like umbrellas probably you take
everything i said before 2015 with a grain of salt
anyway as i was going through some of my older
posts i noticed a whole bunch of products that
i used in the past that i raved about that
i don't really use in my routine anymore so
i thought it would be interesting to go through
them if there's a product that you've completely
discarded from your routine as well let me know
in the comments if you like sciencey beauty
content click the like the subscribe and the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
first up we have the neostrata gel plus
this is a 15% alpha hydroxy acid product
it's got 15% glycolic acid it is a chemical
exfoliant and i was really into this in 2012
this was a really unusual product
back then especially in australia
with this higher concentration of glycolic acid
there were like three products now it's actually
pretty easy to find a chemical exfoliant
there's been so many launched on the market
that i've just never had to repurchase this
i still think it's a really great formula so
neostrata was actually founded by the scientists
who did a lot of the pioneering research on alpha
hydroxy acids and polyhydroxy acids as well but
the market's changed a lot since then and there
are so many great chemical exfoliants that you can
buy for a lot less money and so i don't think it's
really worth it to pay top dollar for a relatively
simple formula neostrata have a lot of really
other great products that are quite unique and i
would recommend getting those over the gel plus
the covergirl lash blast waterproof
so i have trichotillomania and this is
a hair pulling disorder i've never really talked
about this before because it's something that i've
pretty successfully managed to the point where
it doesn't really interfere with my life anymore
except in the realm of eyelashes so basically
trichotillomania is a compulsive hair pulling
disorder it's linked to things like ocd and
anxiety it's reasonably common about 0.9 to
4 percent of the population get it at some point
in their lives and it's more common in women it
started for me when i was about nine when i was
stressed or bored i would just start pulling out
strands of hair from my head it got pretty
bad at one point i had really thin patches
i started getting really frizzy regrowth and my
mom gave me some really hideous haircuts to try
to hide the regrowth i started out by pulling
out the most perfect thick hairs i could find
and then i eventually redirected myself into only
pulling out the kinky frizzy ones which i don't
have that many of and also my eyelashes now when
i'm stressed i'll like search through my hair and
look for like a kinky hair to pull out and also
my eyes get really itchy and so i start yanking
on loose eyelashes a lot of the time when my
eyes are itchy it is actually a loose eyelash
and i also wear rigid contact lenses at night
and if i get a loose eyelash in my eye at the
same time as the rigid contact lens it's really
really painful so it's actually not that bad a
situation to not have loose eyelashes for me but
it does mean that i have really patchy eyelashes
for a while in my early 20s i cared a lot about
this because everyone on youtube had really
big eyelashes they were all putting on false
eyelashes i think it's still a bit like this now
i used latisse to grow eyelashes i got eyelash
extensions once but that was actually a really bad
idea because it actually gave me better grip to
pull out eyelashes but eventually i stopped caring
and i wear really thick eyeliner anyway so it
doesn't really seem to make a massive difference
but if you're wondering why i never wear
mascara or false eyelashes that's why
australian natural skincare so i'm australian
and these brands are really big here they're also
really reasonably priced you get them a lot in
like goodie bags from retailers and i buy a lot of
rose of oil they all sell rosehip oil and a lot of
the time when you buy rosehip oil you get a little
sachet of another one of their products they also
send out pr samples to australian bloggers and so
between 2011 and 2013 i used a lot of these
products and they worked really well on my skin
they tend to have essential oils which isn't
great for sensitive skin but the only brand that i
really reacted to was sukin but there are two big
reasons why i've drifted away from these products
firstly they have a shorter shelf life they use
lots of natural extracts and oils and they use
natural ingredients and so they tend to
go a bit funny in texture after a while
i never noticed any mold or anything but
the texture changes were pretty off-putting
and since i try out lots of different products
for reviews i never really got through a container
properly the other issue is that these brands
tend to lean into those fear-mongering clean
beauty denigrating claims things like they're free
from parabens there's no nasties i've talked about
the issues with clean beauty before probably
most brands on the market at the moment have
some of these claims but they're all varying
levels of that i think out of these the worst
brand is probably sukin for these claims it's a
pretty tricky situation and i'm not really sure
how i should be approaching this so maybe some
of you have some suggestions so like i said i
love rosehip oil i use it a lot i've been using
it a lot recently because you can probably hear
it in my voice but i'm getting over a cold and my
nose is really chapped and rose of oil helps a lot
with that most of the rosehip oils in australia
come from these brands that have some level of
clean marketing and i get these rosehip oils as
pr samples i don't specifically ask for them but
my mailing address is on some pr databases
and i sometimes get them as part of a package
from a big retailer so i have these bottles of
rosehip oil lying around i'm not going to throw
them out and buy rosehip oil from somewhere
else because that's just a massive waste
i want to be honest about what i'm using on my
skin but i also don't want to be really promoting
these brands that use a lot of clean in their
marketing with paid collaborations i started
a policy of not doing paid collaborations with
brands that feature clean a lot in their marketing
and i explain it to the brands when i talk to them
and hopefully they take on that feedback but with
sharing my routine in my instagram stories i'm not
really sure where to draw the line i think most
brands now have some level of these clean claims
in their marketing and sometimes it's really hard
to pick up like you won't necessarily see it on
their instagram sometimes you have to dig into
their blog and i try a lot of different products
out and it's really quite labor intensive to spend
like two hours searching through everything a
brand has ever said before i post like a picture
of the six products i used my routine that
day onto social media and brands change their
marketing all the time and so it can be really
hard to keep track of that anyway i realized
this is a very michelle specific problem and if
anyone has any suggestions i'd be really grateful
lush angels on bare skin i really like this
product it's like a really nice gentle scrub but
again it's that shelf life issue i could just
never get through a tub of this before it went off
and so i started freezing little nuggets
of it in my freezer i still have some in
my freezer i'm pretty sure but it's just
a bit of a hassle and so i've been using
skinfood's pineapple peeling gel
instead as my physical exfoliant
that's also listed in my 2012 favorites
so clearly i'm just a creature of habit
netting sponge on a stick this is a really
efficient way of washing your back and i got this
from daiso so it was $2.80 the problem is netting
sponges tend to grow mold if they don't dry out
properly and since it's all bunched up it doesn't
dry very easily you'll see all these really scary
stories in the medical literature about people
getting infections from these infected sponges
and yeah sponges like this they hang up they
have skin cells and beauty products all over
them and they're wet and so that's like the
perfect place for bacteria to just start
having generations of babies i am actually
quite prone to folliculitis i get it really
easily when my skin's irritated and damp and so i
get it when i have laser hair removal for example
my skin's irritated and i put on that gel
afterwards which is meant to cool it down
that makes me break out in little spots i get
it with period undies because they tend to be
synthetic and they also have this printed label
on the back and that rubs against my skin i get
it from dance classes when i swivel on my butt
because again it's that irritation of friction
i even get it when i wear synthetic clothing and
i don't shower for more than 24 hours which isn't
as gross as it sounds it's like if i shower
in the morning on one day and i don't shower
till the evening of the next day then i tend to
break out in little bumps again anyway i have
no regular schedule my life is chaos i have chaos
dragon energy so i switched to exfoliating towels
instead these towels again you can get it from
daiso i also got one from innisfree and because
they're one big sheet then they dry out a lot more
easily plus you can just chuck them in the wash
seche vite top coat is that even how you pronounce
it i feel like i haven't had to say it for like
years basically this is this amazing top coat
that smooths out your nail polish and makes it
look like it's just all one thing there's no like
bumps or anything it's just smooth and glossy i
pretty much just got lazy and stopped painting
my nails as much and now if i do paint my nails i
want something that lasts for ages so the way that
seche vite works is it kind of just redissolves
everything and then re-dries it into one smooth
layer but that also means that everything just
gets chunked up into one giant layer and so
it peels really easily so now if i paint my
nails i want something that lasts for ages and
so seche vite is just not a great option for me
bb cream so bb cream is like meant to be an
all-in-one product it's got sunscreen and
foundation and skin care all in one but a lot
of the time with all-in-one products it just
doesn't quite do really well in any of the domains
it's like a jack of all trades master of none sort
of situation the big problem with bb cream is
that it's really quite pigmented so it works
well as foundation but you can't really apply
enough of it for it to work well as sunscreen
so if you're applying sunscreen underneath it
then the skincare benefits aren't really there
either because the skincare isn't going to have
an easy time getting to your skin and so it really
just works as foundation and as a foundation
it's not great because most ranges have like
two shades so now i just tend to use sunscreen
and then foundation on top or a tinted sunscreen
that isn't really pigmented so i can apply a lot
of it like the right amount for good protection
benefit coralista this is a blush that's like a
really pretty coral color with a slight shimmer
and it's like a really natural looking shimmer
i actually said it was pigmented in my review
and back in 2012 compared to other australian
blushes it probably was but yeah there's a lot
better products on the market now and with
this product i think if you're quite pale
then it works quite well and i think that's the
case with a lot of benefit products to be honest
a lot of them are designed for pale
people so i switched to a lot more
pigmented blushes now that have a bigger
shade range one of my favorites is milani
so i hope that was an interesting trip down
memory lane do you have products that you've
just completely given up on as well let me
know in the comments if you liked the video
click the like you can also subscribe to my
channel you can also follow me on instagram
@labmuffinbeautyscience and check out my blog as
well see you next time for more nerdy beauty talk